what's your favorite famous game
oh that's another tough question
again it's hard to pick favorites this
most recent game um
i did a youtube video on that won the
pro the brilliancy prize the shiraz
queen sack game
it's the most recent one that comes to
mind
um but then there's the classics there's
there's all these different immortal
games
i should i should really make like a
collection of of my favorite games
and put it into a lychee study ooh this
is raided
ed frost beat me once oh okay let's play
i'm gonna play this slime bishop c5
oh you have to set it tally the dog
um you can set it using the lee chess
command
people in chat can help play this move
i think your thank you sethers me 200 oh
it's
um okay let me focus
not too many things happening let's play
this
i'm gonna play this line bishop d6
thanks to it 95 horatio for my sub gift
happy twitch baby it's joe brune
happy twitch baby joe oh courtesy of 95
horatio wait
oh cause 95 horatio gifted
like an extended subscription which i
didn't know you could do
i've never seen that type of alert
before
well thanks joe resubbing on behalf of
john
oh he was gifted a year-long sub oh wow
well that's that's 12 months nice
thanks for still being here
okay i should stay focused this is a
slightly scary position
um oh
did i mess up f4 coming if i take
there's f4
here here i have check
but my knight's in trouble so i should
probably take with rook
because now f4 i can take the pawn
okay i could play g5
maybe bishop e7
just be safe or i could be aggressive
let's be aggressive
let's have some fun and b5
delayed reverse evans
i wanna um oh
opponents being counter aggressive
huh
this is tricky
there's a really cool line let's let's
start with this
there's a really cool line coming up
oh no my queen
oh no oh wait what
uh oh i didn't see that move
that's a that's a scary move
because if i take i the whole point was
to fork and win the queen back
oh but i can just play king of f8
or if i take no
let's play king i fader h8 let's play
king of f8
queen is still hanging but the idea is
to win back the queen
and then also get initiative also the
bishop's still attacked too
so there's a few threats in the position
[Music]
so we might see queen d5 but then i can
take the bishop
and then takes takes takes and then mate
huh
this is so perplexing is my queen my
queen is pretty much trapped
let's sack okay now i'm actually losing
my queen
but maybe it's okay check then i'll take
the bishop
but there's tricks i'll play 94
and then i'll take the bishop yeah
otherwise this was winning the bishop
i'm in a little bit of trouble here i'm
also down a ton of time
oh oh that was a bad move
ah oh this is really bad
ah my bishop
okay oh this is rated too
ah
please
play this move
ah
so close yet so far
there goes all my things ah
i lost oh man
i got a little bit carried away i was
overly fancy well played that fast
so at first i thought this line was okay
because i was just going to take the
bishop
and enjoy life the problem is queen h5
what to do so i realized that i played
knight here
but then still queen h5
and then i can't i can't stop queen d5 i
tried to
but i allowed queen e5
so well played so much regrets
thanks for subbing regretful chlamydia
did i have i probably had g5
yeah i should have played g5
oh g5 here
i'm not sure if g5 here works maybe here
but it's a difficult position because
look
like this is a really good move because
the bishop's defended and the lights
attacked and then
the rook ends up hanging
so i'm probably just losing here
oh no i'm winning oh i could have taken
this bishop
oh look at this line takes
if i lose the queen i win back the queen
hey helsinki friend continuing the
subgift they got from admiral
thanks so much helsinki friends that's a
crazy position
so it could have worked out maybe but
okay queen diggs h4 was uh
not the best decision
i played bishop d6 remembering there's a
game between
karu yeah hikaru and robert hass
like hikaru played the the evans gambit
it was the first round of u.s
championships 2012.
fast forward to today cargo playing the
bomb clown
man
what do i think of the evans it's
dangerous yeah especially if white's
prepared it's a dangerous opening